good morning John a couple hours after I
went to bed two nights ago my house
started to shake a bunch turns out it's
because the earth under my house was
shaking a bunch to be clear this was not
a serious earthquake I think the biggest
casualty was this pasta sauce but to be
additionally clear it did not prevent
Katherine and I from totally freaking
out and running into the baby's room as
fast as we could to stand there and
watch him sleep as if nothing had
happened at all and not do anything
because it was over by the time we got
there it was a 5.8 on the Richter scale
and if you've been in a 5.8 before you
know that it's sort of like standing on
a train that's moving which is not
nothing like it's not what you expect
the earth to do the Richter scale tells
you pretty much what you want to know
which is how much the earth is moving
maybe it doesn't actually tell us what
we want to know in 2010 if you remember
there was a magnitude 7 earthquake in
Haiti this is a much much bigger
earthquake much more destructive
hundreds of thousands of people died
that year there were 20 other
earthquakes that were stronger than that
earthquake in Haiti and the combined
death toll of all 20 of those more
powerful earthquakes was less than a
thousand people the earthquake in Haiti
was so destructive for two reasons one
it was centered very near several
different large population centers
second because Haiti is such a poor
country the buildings weren't well
constructed and many of them collapsed
so that number 7.0 it tells you
something real information but it
doesn't tell you everything and this is
related to a thing that I've been
thinking about lately because it's that
time of year when people are getting
their advanced-placement test scores
back and I get lots of tweets from
people telling me that crash course
helped them do well on one or the other
of those tests this is great thank you I
give you most of the credit but I'm glad
crash course helped but I also just
think this is a good time to say out
loud that you're not your numbers we're
trying to sort of understand our own
value and our worth in our impact we
look to numbers because they're easy to
understand right I think that we often
draw our confidence from them and when
we see a bad one we lose some of that
confidence and I think that we look to
the things that we quantify whether
that's our AP test scores or our net
worth or our BMI or our like how much we
can benchpress think we look to those
things because they're easy to measure
not because they're actually good
surrogates for our value or how
confident we should be
how much we should like herself there
are many things that are more important
that are just much harder to measure
with numbers like how good you are at
communicating how driven you are how
much you care how thoughtful you are
whether or not you are willing to take
on or even really want to take on things
that are difficult for you we don't even
try to test for that stuff we just hope
that the things we do test for are kind
of like include all that stuff inside of
them somehow John you made a video this
week that had you know not a very
interesting thumbnail that didn't have
your face in it and the title was civil
twilight which is not like Oakley and of
course that video got way fewer views
than the average vlogbrothers video but
if you just measure that by the number
of views you miss the fact that like the
people who watch that video got a very
different experience like I watched that
and it made me think so much more than
the average video i watch and it made me
proud to be your brother it's so easy to
look to numbers to define other people
and to define ourselves as if we're
earthquakes man and I know people have
heard this before and said it in a bunch
of different ways and in places but when
we define ourselves that way it is bad
if humans are seven billion earthquakes
on the planet I want to think less about
how big my shake is more about what my
shake does and who our shake it with and
John I'm happy to be shaking it with you
I'll see you on Tuesday